hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video today is
Wednesday January 11 2023 when I'll be
talking about today is you know sort of
slower moving markets what sort of chart
types make it easier to read the order
flow okay because you know not every
Market moves freely you know up and down
the way mes or ES especially you know
NASDAQ or most markets so there are
markets out there that move slower and
using a time-based chart on slower
moving markets is probably not in your
best interest if you're looking at order
flow so
you know if you haven't already be sure
to subscribe to the channel and you know
if you find at the end you get some
value out of this video be sure to like
the video you know it helps it helps in
in the grand scheme of the YouTube
algorithm all right so you know slower
moving markets right I mean we're all
familiar with markets you know the
e-minis where you know you're getting
four or five point ranges you know 20
ticks Etc but you know on slower moving
markets for example
um some of these interest rates right
the U.S 10-year note
trades it's very difficult to trade on a
time-based chart this is a five minute
chart okay five minutes so one bar is
five minutes and what you're seeing is
basically you know in this for this
basically 11 45 to 12 You're basically
trading the bid offer sometimes you
trade a little bit above sometimes you
trade a little bit below but for a half
hour more or less you're stuck in
this area of trading you know the bid in
the offer the bid in the offer and you
know all markets trade with a bid and
offer but I'm saying it is literally not
moving it is you know trading eight
eight and a half sometimes it goes eight
and a half bid at nine trades of nines
sometimes it goes
um
eight
and a eight offer right here you can see
it trades two at seven and a half but
more or less it's trading eight eight
and a half for about a half hour and
it's tough right it's tough to really
get uh handle a good handle on what's
happening in the order flow when all
you're doing is trading the bid in the
offer and sometimes it can be misleading
because you're getting these you know
what looks like imbalances I mean these
are imbalances but just because it's
just trading back and forth more or less
at eight and a half for 20 minutes so
yeah you have an imbalance 455 against
4101 143 against 3815
um 259 against 28.59 then you got buying
and balance here 147 against
um 26.38 and that's just because we're
literally trading one price that whole
time now there are days where 10 years
do have some very good price movements
directionally you know on Flow driven
markets
um you know on days where there's
there's a big number obviously today was
Wednesday tomorrow I believe Thursday
we've got CPI coming out so you know you
kind of expect it to be a little bit
slow in anticipation of that number but
once that number comes out you you watch
what's going to happen to the 10 years
it's going to it's going to be moving
you're gonna think you're looking at the
e-mini chart but
and this is on a five minute chart so
imagine if you're looking at a one
minute chart you know just for that time
period around you know 11 50 to 12
o'clock today it's
you know it's like watching paint try
more or less you know same thing it's
just hanging around there
um and you're really not going to have
much to go off of because you're not
really trading you're not moving really
you know overflow really helps you in
determining the momentum in the market
right but if it's a market that
just well 10 years are it's a unique
Market because the size is huge you know
bid offers usually for thousands and
behind it there's thousands in the order
book
but once they start moving you'll pay
attention so it's what I've learned you
know over the years and I've traded a
lot of grain markets that also can move
slow especially at certain times of the
year
um you know there's times a year corn
trades like this
is I'll look for things in the Delta you
know what's Delta telling me
um you know I look at the imbalances
because really what you're looking for
is any any pulse in the market okay like
is it is things picking up or not okay
and sometimes it's just a big order
going through
okay it's easy to get all excited about
something oh my gosh you know we got
Stacks selling a balance here right one
two three and be thinking oh this is it
you know Market's gonna sell off and
then it just dies on you
okay so you sort of got to understand
right you want to see some
follow-through in the order flow as well
not just a big order going through
because moves that happen
I mean legitimate moves you know sort of
trending moves you are going to see that
uptick take place but then you're going
to see follow-through trading again this
on a one minute chart it's really hard
to to get any information just because
this Market's not really you know it's
moving bid off or bid offer the higher
bid offer a little bit higher
um you know that's why I've always used
a range based chart when I'm looking at
10 years 30 years five years I don't
look at twos twos
twos really would hardly move I haven't
looked at them in a long time but
if you're looking at a range based chart
it really becomes a lot easier you
really got to be a bit experienced in
the order flow to really understand what
you're looking at and get something out
of a minute a time-based chart in a
market like treasuries so
go to you know a range you could use
three four five you know you're not
going to use an 8 9 10 range chart in
the treasuries
um
three is about as minimum as I would go
I
for many many years for about eight
years I used a four range I've sort of
gone out to a five range just because
you know on some days you could get some
nice movements
um
as well so this is a five range chart
okay and it's just so much easier
because now your view the way you're
looking at the chart is it's based on
price movement
right not movement of time it's not like
okay it's 12 55.
and 43 seconds so in 17 seconds then we
get a new bar forming you know when
you're looking at a range based chart
it's if you know you're trading you know
eight and a half okay well if I trade
nine then a new bar is going to form if
I trade nine and a half I'm going to get
a new bar you know it's like that right
so you're looking sort of at how bars
are forming as price moves so that's
just going to give you a bit of insight
that you probably
would not see well honestly probably
would not see you're just not going to
see on on a time-based chart and the
exact same things that I'm looking at on
you know on uh I think I got e-mini
chart here right if I'm looking at a
normal e-mini chart during the day same
things that I'm looking at right things
I talk about in my videos all the time
I'm also looking whether it's a
time-based chart like in e-mini one
minute chart or a
10-year
5 range chart three range chart is you
know the same things now where it gets
interesting you know the thing that I
really love to key in on on
um 10 years is remember it is a market
that trades a lot of volume okay you see
these bars
you know
45 42 000 contracts 14 000 contracts
thirteen thousand contracts thirty nine
thousand contracts and what's the time
between these bars right you know 820 to
838 so about 15 minutes 40 000 contracts
eight to thirty eight to eight forty one
three minutes fourteen thousand
contracts seven minutes later 13 000
contracts
um you know about 15 minutes later
forty thousand thirty nine point two Etc
so you're getting good volume so what I
love to key in on and I sort of touched
on this
um this last couple of days is not just
where the heavy volume is right because
again that's what everybody's looking at
in terms of book Maps the depth of
Market you know the domes is I'm looking
at those areas for lack of volume areas
where I don't see the normal
order flow go through in a sense and
you know when I first released my
software you know someone asked me I
can't get this up on my ninjatrader what
my software software I use here is the
software that I developed for my own
trading and you know over the years
people have asked me to you know can I
get a copy so we started the
orderflows.com website where you can get
the software but
exhaustion prints you could look for
this on your chart yourself okay you
don't need a software right you have
eyes you know the best I always say the
best computer is the one
on your shoulders right your brain and
really all you're looking for is at the
tops of
well I'll say the tops button but the
ends of moves you're looking for lack of
volume exhaustion okay and it's gonna
make it easy I'll just keep this at
let's keep it at
well the default is nine but I'll keep
it at 10 because we just call it single
print so basically would be looking for
single prints at the edges of the bars
so basically a volume of 10 or under in
the bar I want to be highlighted to it
okay here's a five here's a nine here's
a six right here's a seven
um just so going back a few days right
as the Market's moving down six four six
two one you don't see any exhaustion
prints on the bottom of These Bars the
market starts going up just seven here's
a five
okay and it's just something that you
know at a turning point in the market
normally we're trading thousands of
contracts right we're coming down here
you know three thousand twenty eight
hundred you know here's 800 800 900 two
and a half thousand twenty four hundred
and then seven
foreign
well if the last person
sold or there's nobody interested in
selling anymore what do you think the
Market's going to do so it's not going
to go down it's going to go back up
right and we went back up to these new
highs
here right we had you know again this is
sort of in an area that we've been
trading around you know here it's quite
a time difference from you know one
until two in the afternoon but here
we're sort of going sideways okay well I
got six here so I got I know that the
market came down
from I guess you know 11 traded all the
way down to o5 back up to 09 trade six
okay and it just goes sideways still
holding right trades on nine this time
trade for
several thousand well close to 5 000
contracts then it came back down back
down to 06 and again this bar
created 14 000 contracts
but I only managed to trade five here
I'm looking for this Market to trade
back up because now right we're trading
this bar closes at eight and a half
okay I know at nine we traded some size
here I'm thinking if we can get past
this nine
make a run back up higher
and then what happens boom it gets past
that nine
and it just keeps going up up all the
way up to here right to 13 where you
trade nine contracts and then it
reverses off of that so it went from the
five contracts up to the nine as is
going up it's trading a ton of contracts
two thousand two thousand sixteen
hundred thirty seven hundred five
thousand five thousand six thousand two
thousand okay then Works its way up
twenty eight hundred Seventeen hundred
nine
what do you think Market reverse now
this bar is starting to trade it goes
all the way up to 13 trading back down
at 11 10 and a half I know that this
thing's just sticking out there it's
just telling me Mike
nobody was interested in taking it
higher at this moment I mean that
doesn't mean that it can't go higher the
rest of the day of course it can but for
now
based off the information that's
available to the trading world there's
just no interest in taking it higher but
then it came
right back down
to six and a half
right how do you trade it you just get
short in here after this bar closes 10.
down to nine down to eight down to seven
okay now remember Ten Years trades in
half ticks half tick is a little full
tick is two half ticks which is you know
31.25 so
once half of that I can't do the math 16
bucks or something like that
15 no 15 61 25
so again you know if you're going to key
on something whether it's if I'm looking
at this on a
five range chart if I'm looking on a
three range chart I'd be looking for the
same things I'll be looking for those
areas
of lack of volume on the edges right the
edges of the moves
okay for areas where it's coming in okay
um you know it's a little bit different
here on the three range but I see a two
here right on the edge of this move
there's a 9 here that's that nine from
earlier I believe here's your five okay
you got a little bit in here a one and a
three
but these are not at the edge of moves
right this is the low it goes up here
you're sort of retesting this low from
earlier then it goes up you trades nine
and on the three range it looks a little
bit more bearish simply because you had
that big aggressive buying coming in
here
with no follow through trades nine right
after a big stack buying and balance
okay so again you know if and I know
guys that's all they look for right they
trade these 10 years the beauty of 10
years is you can move a ton of style
I'll say a ton of size you can move good
size
20 contracts 30 contracts 50 contracts
even without affecting the market and
since you could move size and it's a
liquid Market you don't have to getting
20 ticks out of the move you could just
you know I know guys that's the whole
strategy is just to pull four or five
ticks out of a move in the 10 years just
because they trade
50 contracts
so that's it anyway guys
I hope you guys found this video useful
I I apologize it sort of started out
kind of Rocky on this video but my point
is you know when you're looking at a
Market that just it doesn't move as
the way es moves trying to look at a
time-based chart isn't probably going to
be in your best interest look at a range
based chart on slower moving markets
because you really want to take into
account how the market is moving to take
advantage of it so thanks everyone I'll
catch you guys on the next video bye bye